[Applaudissements]
je me présente je m'appelle arnaud
hauchard moi je vous vois pas mais c'est
la première fois que je t'ai être mais
bon a priori vous voyez je suis grand
maître international du jeu d'échecs
j'ai été capitaine pendant presque dix
ans des équipes nationales
chez les femmes que chez les hommes et
j'ai aussi entraîner les jeunes pendant
très longtemps et par exemple maxime
vachier lagrave qui a été numéro 2
mondial il y a deux trois mois et je
vais entraîner pendant huit ans jusqu'à
l'amener à 2740 lots bons c'est assez
technique mais il était déjà un très bon
niveau avant qu'ils nous quittent pour
pour un club plus riches ce que vient
d'ouvrir
bon alors pour la petite anecdote je
suis recorman du monde un record assez
stupide basé sur la privation de sommeil
lorsque manuel valls a voulu que le club
d'evry devienne le champion de france
j'ai voulu marquer le coup au téléthon
en faisant un record du monde privation
de sommeil et de parties d'échecs
non-stop et bizarrement là quand même
sur la photo là vous voyez s'était
jamais en forme 80 3h39 s'entend bien à
jouer aux échecs non stop
alors évidemment je suis connu pour ça
un petit peu et j'ai déjà l'étiquette de
joueur original alors évidemment je vous
déconseille de de faire ce genre de
concours c'est un peu comme les concours
de nourriture j'ai fait les deux
voiliers ça va pas vraiment réussi et
j'ai jamais récupéré le sommeil que
j'avais quand j'étais bébé
donc c'était vraiment stupide mais bon
c'était une expérience alors contact des
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux que j'ai
fréquenté durant toute ma carrière je me
suis intéressé à la personnalité des
joueurs parce que finalement on apprend
plus parfois deux heures face à face
face à un adversaire que toute une vie
de camaraderie c'est là où on verrait
mal véritablement le le joueur se
dévoile
et donc le corollaire entre la
personnalité et le style de jeu aux
échecs et la façon dont les gens se
comportent en dehors de l'échiquier et
je me suis intéressée à tous ces
personnages illustres et actuels qui
sont des grands champions par exemple un
un joueur modeste sur l'échiquier comme
j'en ai rencontré des gens qui ne volent
pas vraiment le conflit qui veulent
jouer tranquillement peuvent pas ne
peuvent pas devenir de grands champions
et c'est un peu comme dans la vie quand
on n'a pas d'ambition on peut pas se
plaindre après d'avoir loupé sa vie il
faut forcément un moment donné prendre
des risques et avoir l'ambition
a contrario a contrario lorsque je suis
tombé sur des gens très très arrogant
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'ego échec
on risque aussi d'avoir des problèmes
dans sa vie professionnelle
le manque de diplomatie le sentiment de
supériorité
il faut éviter tout ça c'est très
mauvais et beaucoup de joueurs se sont
plantés et ont été très arrogant et se
sont ils ont eu beaucoup d'ennemis et
finalement à la fin ils sont restés
isolés
donc il faut aussi savoir raison garder
alors pour la petite histoire
anciennement j'étais au club du noun
chez scop qui n'existe plus un club dans
le 16e et comme vous le voyez à l'époque
c'était dsk qui jouait au club du noun
chess club
hélas après bon changement d'un petit
peu changement de style live rien c'est
sur la gauche où vous reconnaissez
manuel valls la première fois que j'ai
affaire à un homme politique d'envergure
à l'époque en plus il est très très il
était très très connu et il avait un
style de jeu assez tortueux assez
puissant très fort joueur d'échecs ce
sont les deux meilleurs hommes
politiques joueur d'échecs il avait un
style est apprécié des parties longues
les parties ou l'étrangler petit à petit
comme le boa constrictor sa proie et il
n'avait pas du tout envie de gagner
rapidement
il aimait s'asseoir de longueur et de
prendre son temps et de tendre des
pièges de changer c'était il faisait
tout un film à travers la partie et
l'apprécier évidemment jouer de cette
façon par la suite en 2009 lorsque j'ai
rejoint le club de débris j'ai eu
l'occasion d'affronter manuel valls sur
l'échiquier et j'étais surpris par la
différence de style et là tout de suite
ils attaquent sans fioritures il prend à
la gorge il veut le combat direct et il
a un jeu presque comme dans un livre
ouvert et plutôt impatient étrangement
ça ça représente un petit peu ce qui
reflète à travers les médias et et j'ai
trouvé ça assez amusant et j'ai donc
comparé à peu près toutes les
personnalités que je connaissais et la
façon dont ils jouent aux échecs
et finalement quand on veut connaître un
adversaire politique ou un adversaire il
suffit simplement d'étudier son style
aux échecs et on apprend beaucoup de
choses sur lui alors la différence entre
les grands champions
les champions où les forces d'amateurs
c'est évidemment le travail colossal
bon je pense que ici beaucoup de gens
savent ce que ça écrire le travail ça ça
fait la différence mais aux échecs aussi
il faut se remettre en question quand
vous perdez il ya beaucoup de joueurs
qui disent toujours c'est la faute à pas
de chance c'est j'étais malade je crois
en cette variante
il faut accepter de voir la réalité en
face et de combler un peu laissé lacunes
et de pointer ses faiblesses j'ai eu le
cas d'experts jeu l'expérience avec des
joueurs très talentueux mais qui avait
un ego surdimensionné
donc il ne m'écoutait pas il n'écoutait
plus le et les amis les conseils des
maîtres du passé et finalement ils ne
voyaient pas leurs erreurs parce que
pour eux il était fort dans tous les
domaines mais lieu de jeu début final on
ne pouvait rien leur dire c'était la
faute à pas de chance
en général ces joueurs là ne font pas
grand chose non plus donc voilà les
excès c'est souvent mauvais tous les
champions que j'ai rencontré dans ma vie
ont eu pour objectif non seulement de
bien jouer mais un peu de révolutionner
le jeu c'est ce qui fait aussi la marque
d'un grand champion par exemple sans
entrer dans un détail que l'inter ait
trop technique
un fou vaut trois points un cavalier un
pareil on résume en termes de pions et
certains préfèrent les fous certains
préfèrent les cavaliers dans l'état
actuel de l'évolution du jeu on ne sait
toujours pas c'est ça le mystère aussi
du jeu si le fou est supérieur aux
cavaliers éternel débat qui parfois m'a
fait faire des nuits blanches
j'ai toujours d'ailleurs à titre
d'exemple maxime vachier lagrave donc
qui est devenue la super star que que
l'on sait dès l'âge de 8 9 ans comme
s'il était déjà adulte
il comprenait que c'était le moment déjà
pour ingurgiter des tas de connaissances
et il a toujours été à leur âme et court
toujours été polis toujours à l'écouté
des maîtres du passé beaucoup de respect
pour ceux qui ont fabriqué finalement
surtout les échecs soviétique puisque ce
sont eux les précurseurs en matière de
renouvellement du jeu et
et aussi il était toujours à la page
c'est à dire dans la modernité
fréquenter des amis ou fort joueur de
son de son âge se mettre à la pointe de
haut niveau technologique avec le
meilleur ordinateur les modules et il
vivait avec son temps mais il a utilisé
les bons côtés dans les deux dans les
deux dans les deux sphères chez les
anciens et chez les modernes
alors il y là quand il a commencé à
jouer aux échecs il a tous les principes
et les préceptes du jeu est là qui ça
rapidement et au début de l'adolescence
vers 12-13 ans il a commencé à déjà à
réagir comme un champion c'est à dire
que il a il voulait m'épater c'est à
dire qu'ils connaissaient maintenant
presque tous que ce que ce que je sais
actuellement mais il voulait montrer sa
patte disant voilà j'ai trouvé ça j'ai
révolutionner ce ce début j'ai trouvé de
nouvelles idées je suis sûr qu'on peut
réfuter la nage of la ccid etc
les termes techniques et donc c'était ça
la marque des champions il ne se
contentait pas simplement de d'apprendre
et de comprendre mais il voulait innover
il aimait déjà souffrir comme tous les
champions
bon on préfère gagner mais à l'époque il
jouait contre magnus carlsen je me
souviens très bien au tournoi de
lausanne
magnus carsen qui est le champion du
monde actuel est le meilleur joueur de
tous les temps probablement il y avait
eu des luttes acharnées avec maxime
et même quand ils perdaient il était
heureux d'avoir tout donné et il aimait
se transcender sur l'échiquier être
souffrir vraiment des données le mieux
parce qu'il savait qu'une opportunité
pareille d'aller ne pouvait ne pas se
représenter donc il donnait toujours le
maximum contre un champion il a même
d'ailleurs à son scalp plusieurs
champions du monde
évidemment on n'est pas de numéro deux
mondial par hasard alors j'ai beaucoup
voyagé à peu près 50 pays puisque on
n'aime pas beaucoup d'argent aux échecs
spécialement mais on est souvent en
voyage donc fait tous les pays et donc
effectivement j'ai une grande expérience
des échecs à travers le monde
alors je me suis je me suis intéressé
aux pays émergents je suis allé en chine
en inde et aux états unis et je
comprends je comprends mieux ce qui nous
sépare de ces pays là parce que pour
pourquoi nous sommes en train d'avoir du
retard sur les pays comme la chine et
l'inde
me direz vous en france en france chaque
jeune à un ordinateur une tablette un
téléphone tout lui est acquis il descend
de chez lui et prend le métro il a déjà
le meilleur club de france
ambac sully pour ceux qui ont la chance
d'habiter en ile de france on ouvre la
porte qui ouvre la porte à un maître
international ou un grand m comme c'est
le cas à evry pour eux c'est tout à fait
normal sauce pas de questions seulement
quand tu vas en chine ou en inde
il faut faire parfois mille kilomètres
pour trouver un maître international je
parle même pas de grand maître
mais les régions aux états unis cité
dans le lard kansas bon courage pour
trouver un professeur d'échec alors
lorsque j'étais à l'étranger pendant les
championnats du monde où les
championnats en europe plutôt
championnat du monde c'est ce qui nous
concerne
jeune j'ai donné des stages bénévolement
enfin je voulais connaître les jeunes
pays je voulais savoir ce que les
vietnamiens les chinois avaient dans le
ventre et donc je veux partager mon
savoir avec les jeunes et je voulais
j'étais curieux de voir un peu leurs
méthodes d'apprentissage j'ai aussi
discuté que les entraîneurs de ces pays
là alors pendant que les enfants de ma
délégation se décontracter
en dehors des cours dans les chambres
d'hôtel à jouer à la playstation
aller sur facebook lol j'ai fait nul
j'ai gagné alors qu'eux ils se sont vus
cinq minutes avant au déjeuner il
reparle de la partie alors que bon eh
bien pendant ce temps là les les petits
chinois les indiens les les les
gens qui n'avaient pas à tout sur un
plateau d'argent il me regarde et me
regarder avec un regard pétillant et
avides d'informations et de
connaissances
malgré tout ce qui fait la différence
entre la vie réelle de certaines
professions et des échecs
c'est pour l'instant le niveau
technologique n'est pas déterminant
c'est à dire que
un joueur qui viendrait du fin fond de
l'inde s'il tombe sur un maître
international et de vieux bouquins
pourra très vite devenir un champion n'a
pas besoin d'avoir le dernier ordinateur
et la dernière collection dans certains
d'un certain certains trains certains
certaines professions on a encore on a
encore de la vence et on peut on peut
encore se reposer sur nos avancées
technologiques
mais en ce moment j'ai remarqué enfin il
est même très probable et dans quelques
années on retrouve plus de joueurs
occidentaux dans le top 100 mondial
même sur le court terme on n'arrivera a
glissé de 3 européen mais en ce moment
il ya des joueurs indiens et chinois qui
sortent tous les jours des grands
maîtres qui ont le couteau entre les
dents et qui veulent leur part du gâteau
parce qu'ils ont le culte du travail
on leur a appris à l'école qu'il fallait
travailler et les échecs c'est comme
n'importe quel sport enfin je technique
c'est un petit peu l'inconvénient des
échecs c'est que pour savoir jouer
correctement il faut quand même déjà
apprendre pas mal de choses c'est ce qui
rebute un peu les les gens qui
voudraient s'amuser l'ondé fois vers le
poker c'est quand même plus simple il
est courant en france de rencontrer des
professeurs des pays de l'est du blog de
l'ancien bloc de l'est et à l'époque je
ne lui était pas rendu compte mais on
avait accueilli et boris spassky qui a
été champion du monde d'échecs y aussi
leurs fans entraient dans la classe
pauvre of des candidats au titre mondial
ça on ne s'est pas rendu compte de la
chance qu'on avait on disait oui on est
bien content d accueillir voilà il fut
le régime communiste mais non c'était
fantastique
on n'a pas réussit alors à vraiment à
les accueillir comme il fallait il
fallait vraiment profiter d'eux et faire
des tas de choses avec eux non on les
accueille bon voila il file system mais
on s'était pas rendu compte du tout la
chance qu'on avait et au fil des années
j'ai remarqué aussi que mes élèves
commencer un feignant t en france c'est
à dire que maintenant que tout est
accessible d'un clic il faut que je
marche je prémat je travaille les arbres
de tri sûreté le coup tu joues ça tu
cliques et maintenant ils sont tous du
pacifique passivité incroyable
au lieu d'être interactif et de discuter
avec des copains disons qu est ce que tu
joues sur camaïeu 5
je me souviens quand je frappais les
coûts sur l'échiquier
et bien là il clique il en ingurgitait
clic et finalement maintenant ils
attendent que tous leurs soient servis
sans vraiment faire le véritable effort
ils ne vont plus chercher les
informations eux-mêmes ils attendent
qu'on fasse tout le boulot alors il est
évident que si l'europe de la vieille
europe ne se réveille pas on va
continuer à perdre du terrain
il faut se remettre en question et
retroussé ses manches
malheureusement le court bar aux échecs
peut s'arrêter rapidement et on va boire
un coup et tout à tout est tranquille
mais dans la vie de tous les jours
c'est une autre paire de manches mais le
constat imparable
il suffit de voir comment ça se passe
aux échecs l'an problème des européens
c'est l'enfant roi et le sentiment de
supériorité qu'on a par rapport aux
autres
et des fois quand on perd un je ne me
dis je plein vous propose de regarder
sur czech base j'étais gagnant j'ai
perdu contre un indien qui a 200 pour l
aude - et ouais mais il a joué jusqu'au
bout et il connaissait ses échos et
voilà il a travaillé plus que toi il a
il a été au fond des choses il a il se
souvient de 2 to et et voilà et
maintenant ça fait mal ben oui t'as beau
avoir le dernier ordinateur dernier cri
ça n'a pas suffi bien sûr il existe en
savoir faire français même aux échecs
on a une culture d échec importante mais
il faut se remettre en question et
malheureusement ou heureusement c'est je
ne sais pas vraiment jeu ça va de plus
en plus vite maintenant l'ordinateur est
tellement fort que effectivement on peut
plus vivre mais il faut ce qu'il faut
il faut aussi maintenant s'habituer à
rencontrer des joueurs
voilà deux avec des styles différents il
faut se mettre à la page et évoluer et
maintenant si on veut exister faut
travailler travailler et travailler
malgré tout il faut pas que cela
devienne une obsession de travail parce
que j'ai eu des cas de joueurs d'échecs
qui ont vies qu'ils ont vécues comme des
stakhanovistes dans des à 700 en coupant
tout le lien social qu'ils avaient avec
les autres pour s'enfermer dans une
chambre et comme vous savez dans les
films et dans les oreilles dans les
livres ça se termine souvent mal un
petit tour un petit tour à la chp et
c'est pour ça que il faut s'ouvrir au
monde et connaître ses adversaires en
dehors de l'échiquier ça nous apprend
beaucoup
et ce sont des armes supplémentaires
parce que lorsqu'on connaît le caractère
des gens en dehors on peut deviner un
petit peu ce qui va se passer dans les
parties et on peut s'adapter
donc non plus ne pas aller dans l'excès
avec le progrès technologique la halle à
la face du monde a changé la façon de
penser à changer il faut maintenant
aller plus en plus vite dans plein de
domaines par exemple j'ai remarqué
qu'une nouvelle reste de champion vient
d'apparaître maintenant on a les gens un
peu enfermé un peu autiste on dit entre
guillemets mais on a beaucoup moins de
gens arrogants comme avant où les
champions rakaa mais la revanche en
disant je suis supérieur j'ai tout
compris aux échecs parce que
l'ordinateur n'était pas là pour les
contredire
maintenant un simple clic j'ai joué
comme une truffe même le grand maître
karl scène qui est champion du monde n'a
pas vraiment de choses contre un
ordinateur lente sur un module contre un
module sur un ordinateur lambda il
perdrait malheureusement c'est triste ça
retire un peu de charme et de poésie et
enfin de romantisme aux échecs mais bon
c'est la vision la vision réaliste du
jeu il faut pas chercher le meilleur
coût il faut il faut il faut
contrecarrer l'adversaire maintenant il
faut laisser tomber l'idée qu'on touche
le la vérité est le graal c'est une
perte d'énergie
c'est pareil dans votre vie ne cherchait
pas à être plus malin que les autres sur
un domaine il faut simplement maintenant
dans ce domaine concurrentiel est
meilleur que les autres donc il faut
embêter l'adversaire aux échecs c'est
très simple parce que après on restent
bons amis on a embêté l'adversaire
pendant le pendant le match mais par
exemple un joueur qui aime échanger les
pièces et ben on retient ces pièces ont
l'énergie un joueur qui aime perdurer
des parties ont la grèce tout de suite
donc il est plus important d'être
pragmatique et de jouer
les coups les plus efficaces alors
apprenez comprenez bien ce que vous
apprenez bien sûr et essayer de jouer le
bon coup au bon moment parce que comme
dans la vie il n'y aura pas 36
opportunités des joueurs ont perdu le
titre de champion du monde sur un coup
il faut choisir le bon coup au bon
moment et comme ça c'est là vous pouvez
vous aurez tout tenter vous n'aurez rien
à regretter
donc il faut saisir les opportunités et
je terminerai par une phrase de tartas
qu'aux verts qui a été un grand champion
français qui a dit à juste titre celui
qui prend des risques peut perdre et
mais celui qui n'en prend pas perdre a
toujours voilà
[Applaudissements]